usually it's me in the studio after
everybody's gone home two in the morning
and it's a matter of what entertains me
you know that keeps me interested am I
happy working on it that's usually first
the first line you know is does it does
it does it keep me awake do I think
about it am I happy with it you know I
wasn't Dumbo for 20 years I've moved to
Gowanus the Venice of Brooklyn you know
I've got it's a big place you know
20,000 square feet when I'm cranked up
about 20 people full time so it's it's a
you know a lot of people in the office a
lot of people in production and then the
foundries I saw bout two foundries that
have maybe a hundred and fifty people
working for them so there's a lot of
it's a very traditional kind of time it
the work consumes a lot of time I'm kind
of an exception in that I'll model the
sculptures myself I actually make this
sculpture so the part I like so i'll
start with water-based clay I'll use my
hands I'll make a small model these days
were scanning you know with laser scans
and doing using that for you there
enlargements or animation and it's very
the process itself very traditional lost
wax you know we'll make the models and
the plasters and and molds and then send
those to the boundaries and don't take
care